hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the 1857 first
American chess congress in Game three of
their match lupus and versus Paul
Charles Murphy now in Game two morphe
had a brilliant victory he won't game
won then in Game two he had a like I
said I'm brilliant victory but then he
reversed the move order supposedly
because of Paulson's long thinking over
sometimes over or even over an hour for
one move and in the end morphe just
switch to move order and played a
suboptimal line which ended the game in
a draw and the more people was he was
very well even depressed by by this
result and it is something that will
we'll see
take effect in this game so this is a
game three without further ado let's
check it out Paulson with the white
pieces opens with E for with E 5 from
morphe Knight f3 knight c6 and now
Knight to c3 I'm going for the three
Knights opening in the Bishop to c5 by
morphe Bishop to b5
and now d6 we have d4 so all standard
stuff at the time he captures on d4
Knight captures and now Bishop to d7
unpinning preparing to win material here
so Knight captures and c6 beak actress
and now Bishop the back to a for
something that today when you would not
play today would either go c4 d3 or e2
but in those days a4 was considered fine
and here we have Queen to h4 immediately
by morphe already threatening mate and
well I will mention it is as a movie
that the disposition has never been
repeated again
so Paulsen has to defend he castles here
and now Knight to f6 we have Queen the
f3 bringing the Queen to help out with
the defense and already Knights the g4
just going all out he's not like I said
he was very unimpressed with how he
played the previous game so he really
wants the crushed balls in this game
Bishop to f4 defending also you can play
some like Queen G bishop g3 to kick away
the Queen and now Knight to e5 asking do
you want to capture or do you want to
move the Queen here pause and moves the
Queen offers a Queen trade and Morphy
declines Queen to f6
and we have rook a to d1 bringing the
rook into the game with h6 by morphine
preparing g5 to force the ADEA exchange
on e5 and here kink the h1 by Paulsen
always a useful move you will be able to
move your F pawn so very useful g5 by
morphe and now Bishop captures an e5
with D captures on e5 and now we reach a
certain position where there is a secret
hidden in the position but even though
this game was played in 1857 there is a
super disgusting engine line hidden here
so if you're interested maybe you can
even pause the video and try to spot it
while I give you a couple of seconds as
it really is a nice one so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations
as both Paulson and morphe missed it now
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's a rook capture Sun
d7 and I'm sure a lot of you thought of
this move but then you ask yourselves
okay but what then the point is after
King characters you didn't go knighted
d5 you attack the Queen and of course
capture is impossible due to the pin so
let's say Queen e6 you get the Queen out
of the way now comes Queen to c3
threatening to pick up the bishop and
also putting more pressure on c6 so
black has to do something about this
bishop here if here then you allow
Bishop captures here just picking up the
rook so you cannot go there you could go
to d4
38 to attack the Queen but then comes
Queen to d3 and the next you're gonna
complete you're gonna play c3 either win
back the bishop or kick away the bishop
and then you have a lot of nasty
discoveries as the king is still here so
it's it would be a very difficult
position to play for example if you move
your King let's say somewhere then you
can even go Knight to be for putting
more pressure on c6 and white will just
constantly be better but after Queen to
c3 attacking the bishop you don't have
to go back up here you could play
something else like Bishop to b6 but now
you play rook to d1 and now again you're
threatening a lot of very nasty
discoveries and after you hide the King
King c8
now you play Bishop captures and c6 and
if black insists on not giving back any
material for example rook to b8
now Quinta c4 and now there's the threat
of just Queen to a6 check which will be
deadly again if you if you bring the
king over to the defiled the rook is
here you will be presented a lot of
nasty discoveries so again you have to
play something like disappeared to block
the rooks influence over the defiled but
again you're gonna go c3 and that's just
it you're completely winning here not
much to do for black here you cannot
move the bishop because Queen a6 just
ends the game and it's it's just game
over
so this in fact was in the position
after this D captures on e5 by morphe so
g5 and that whole plan really really not
working out but it's it's to be expected
as morphe really i didn't take more than
five minutes for a single move but here
Paulson misses the idea Boston first
place b4 he wants to prepare this line
he sees fractions of the line but not
the whole idea he now wants morphe to
capture so he can just capitalize on it
characters characters and now Knight
attacks the Queen and the bishop so
Queen defends the bishop and now you go
captures captures and here you will just
have a winning game rogue d1 check
you're gonna move the King rush of
characters here now attacking the bishop
and it's it's extremely hard to defend
here this rook is doing nothing this
rope is doing nothing Queen to g4 is
just a huge threat so not much you can
do here Queen Queen will capture on e5
you can it's impossible to defend if you
make some breathing room for the King
even ideas like Rudy's Rita here once
the King who goes to b8 and it's just
game over so that's what Paulsen wants
would be for of course morphine not
interested in that Bishop back to d6 and
now rook to d3 preparing to double up
rooks on the D file and Morphy continues
happily attacking on the Kings side with
h5
with rook F to D 1 and now first a6 by
morphe with probably gaining more
control over b5 it's a it's not not an
easy move to decipher what what Murphy's
idea was here for example if if he goes
for example to d8 right away then b5
might be
be a nice break through for example be
five characters captors and probably
probably to prevent this from happening
if Bishop captures Knight captures you
will have a lot of pressure here also
maybe the pawn will now be under attack
so a6 does seem like like a useful idea
but okay now we have Knights the e2 by
volson ARIMA nuvaring the night making
room for the pawn here he wants to play
a 3 C 4 and C 5 and now look the d8 by
morphine we have a 3 now strengthening
the b4 pawn and here G for morphine out
prepares to push h4 we have c4 and here
morphe first goes to Queen to h6 the
problem with h4 right away is that more
if he doesn't like what happens after it
for example Queen to III now g3f
captures and now if you want to bust
open you don't want to play characters
and then allow white h3 this is how we
break through you push h3 right away G
captures Bishop captures and now after
Bishop characters and c6 with checking
your fate this c5 move comes and it is a
it is a pretty crazy position there
should be seven rook captures Bishop
captures and the white should always be
a little bit better as he is up two
pawns and there is nothing concrete for
black here it would be it would be a
crazy game of course but white should be
better
so after c4 Morphy first goes Queen to
h6 his idea now that if qui never
retreats the e3 he would in fact be be
glad to trade Queens so c5 Paulsen
continues with its planned
we have aged for now and in between move
Queen to e3 and first now Bishop to e7
he says ok you you trade I'm gonna
capture with the rook and my rook is a
well it's neither than on c6 to keep an
eye on the c6 pawn so f4 by Paulsen
saying what do you do here
Murphy says ok characters on f4 we have
Queen captures on f4 and only now Murphy
trades we have Queen captures Knight
captures and now quickly rook to h6 as
the rook is important for the protection
of the c6 pawn as you'll see later in
the game so Knight back to e 2 by
Paulsen and now comes F 5 by morphine
but this allows Paulson at advanced the
pawn to e5 and here it's a it's a really
difficult position for Morphy he has to
play something these pieces are really
terribly placed if Bishop the c8 then
let's say you just trade captures
characters you're going to go Knight to
d4 put pressure on c6 and there's just
no good way to defend this if you go
here then you have a bunch on b7 which
is basically a pawn if you go here just
east six is completely winning not much
to do here if characters captures and of
course if no sorry if if six and you
capture with with the bishop then you
can just pin it with rook to e1 so
that's not really gonna work and after
each six if you capture with the rook
then well you just give up give up the
exchange for nothing not really not
really doing anything there but point is
if Bishop here rook pins and now you
just threaten to capture it so you'd
have to defend it King to have seven but
he still just capture a knight captures
rook captures and Bishop b3 will just
win material and that's just it
so after E 5 more feet didn't find a a
good idea and it's very hard to find a
good idea of something like Bishop to g5
and continue to somehow improve your
position more if you decided to play
rook the e6 block the pawn this way and
just threaten to pick it up because it's
not easy to defend it for example if
rook to e3 Bishop g5 you again kick away
the rook
however this blunders the game
completely for morphine and once again
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the do winning move for Paulsen
here while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
paying attention that the rook is
crucial for the defense of the c6 pawn
congratulations and for those of you who
just wanna enjoy show its Knight to f4
you give a b5 pawn but morphine no
longer gets control of the c6 pawn so
there's not much to do here morphe
captured on e5 but now comes roof
capture Sun d7 rook captures and e7 and
now Bishop captures and c6 that's why
rook to h6 and Queen to h6 were always
eyeing that c6 pawn here you don't have
a way of of
to defend on d7 so more feet right
Bishop to d6 but it doesn't help much
seek a person d6 we have C captures on
d6 and now pause and just started to
bring his king inter game so he doesn't
get checkmated on the back rank morphe
unpinned and here we have Bishop
captures on d7 and it was in this
position that Paul chose morphe resigned
the game yes that is the first time
we've heard those words and it is it is
shocking and hard to hear I know but it
did happen
Game three of their match in 1857 in the
first American chess congress went to
Louis Paulson do mention this to your to
your friends at the bar in the library
point is after captures there's really
not all that much to do here you are
your upper piece and even though morph
is up a pawn it's unplayable even the
great morphe doesn't there continue to
play this position so that's something
that will eart fisk mentioned in his
letter that we started reading in the
previous video but we didn't continue
the letter he said that because of that
fiasco in game two were he blundered the
the move order and then only only got a
draw that he was really really depressed
and which of course you you could see in
this game his play was just not on the
level of the morph you used to basically
in this game pulse and was morphe if he
if we found some better lines but morphe
just play it played like a barbarian he
just wanted to check my pulse and pulse
and defend it properly and then in the
end the morphe just had undeveloped
pieces that were pretty much doing
nothing so even the great morphe had had
his bad moments and this is one of them
so it's it's important to check that out
as well but yeah that's game three of
their match we're continuing of course
with with game four and i would just
like to mention to everyone that
tomorrow we have a leech chess team
battle i like the one we've already had
so if you if you guys are interested I
will put two links in the description
below one will be to the tournament page
and one will be where you can join our
team if you wanna join our team to fight
in the arena
it starts at 2:00 p.m. GMT or that's 3
p.m. Central Central European Time so do
check it out if you can and I will
I will also be streaming if my
internet service provider you know
provides me with the service of Internet
and we'll see how it goes but yeah
that's it between the two of them
now we're continuing their match in the
next video I would like to thank
Isengard son Harry Hoffman Simonis
plunge nice bow Jonas and Owen Lindsey
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous video
serum thank you for watching and I will
see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Paul
Morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and of course
whatever else happens in the chess world
which of course isn't much at the moment
a madea thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day